okay
are we back
all right
so
overtime oh i remember the the guy from
the beginning comes now we haven't done
this in a while it's coming back to me i
remember you you're on the beginning of
the show
okay for the panel is the mainstream
media being unnecessarily harsh to
president biden well apropos what i was
just talking about um
i don't know
what do you think i would say yes the
biden presidency has been far more
successful
than the media has made it out to be i
mean he passed the bipartisan
infrastructure
investment at a time when bipartisanship
has never been more
elusive we've seen the fastest decline
in unemployment to 3.9 percent we've
seen the fastest rate of economic growth
in nearly four decades we've seen the
creation of more than six million jobs
it's far from perfect but by every
objective by most objective metrics it's
been a success so why is his numbers so
in the toilet
okay i think we live in a
hyper-polarized political climate
in which each political party has a
perverse incentive to portray the other
as the root of all evil
and claim that the apocalypse is lurking
at every moment
and just given the polarization in
america there's going to be a ceiling on
how popular every future president will
be unfortunately but okay that's the i
get to the republicans he's not going to
get that 50 but he's not doing great
with the democrats either
and he's doing terribly with
independence i mean
i look at glenn younkin's victory
for the governorship in virginia a state
that went 10 points for biden why did he
win
because
the new swing voter it's not the soccer
mom it's the covid mom it's people who
are absolutely enraged that two years
into this virus things still haven't
gotten back to normal their kids are
suffering learning loss and depression
they're watching what their kids are
learning on zoom and it's like you know
anti-racism but it's kind of neo-racist
um and crime and the things that have
sort of become untouchable for democrats
to talk about they should be running
away with this right now why aren't they
i think any president would have a tough
time with this pandemic and the longer
the pandemic goes on the harder it is
for any head of state to be popular and
i think this will probably turn around
in in six months
but i mean the the other thing which i
think is going on here is that a
president is judged by laws you
mentioned two very important ones if the
democrats had two more senators we'd be
living in the transformed country and i
think biden would be a much more popular
president
okay
um why isn't trump in jail yet i know
you're going to applaud um
all the commit crimes he's committed
were done in plain sight and on national
tv well that's ridiculous hardly all the
crimes he's given i mean but yes i i
i always said that was his
is you know i always say he's not only
stupid he's crazy you have to understand
that about trump he's stupid and crazy
the crazy part is like he just speaks
his interior monologue he said recently
just like a few days ago he said
something about it's not who votes who
counts the votes i mean stalin used to
say it but
privately stalin said it privately he
says it right out and there's something
about that when you do a crime in public
people don't think it's a crime it's
like the guy who cheats on his wife at
the middle of the restaurant with some
honey would i be if i was [ __ ] her
would i be eating with her at the most
popular restaurant in town
but you know
that's his crate the crazy works for him
i mean it's a sign of i mean sadly i
think it's a sign of how we're between
two stools as a country if we were you
know if we were a proper authoritarian
regime
and you carried out a failed coup
something very bad would happen to you
right right
right we're not there right
right
if we were a proper rule of law right
right and you carried out a failed queue
you would be prosecuted as happens in
other democracies
we are somewhere in between right is our
problem you're right turkey they tried
one on erdogan a couple of years ago
remember that
and those people are not
sitting home
watching shark tank
[Music]
they are
dead or in jail yes i mean he was
ruthless about that and you're right
we're in the middle so we yeah we
because that was a cool attempt and it
doesn't matter he's still out there
anything else
is that enough
over time or do we
i think overtime is short we go back to
west side story
thank you very much
[Applause]
you